[Musique]
le 1er mars 1969 le marché des halles
quitter définitivement le quartier où il
se tenait depuis plus de huit siècles la
fin des pavillons allait-elle signifier
la mort du quartier peut-être pas une
nouvelle vague de commerçants
brocanteurs restaurateurs marchand d'art
fripiers s'installe tous les jours dans
un quartier que les anciens ne
reconnaissent plus pour les uns le
quartier rené pour les autres il est
presque mort
[Musique]
place des innocents cet ancien
mandataire des halles
aujourd'hui installé à rungis n'a jamais
voulu quitter son quartier
je pouvais voter le pen parce que je
laissais derrière nous à ce qui me
concerne ça va j'essaie d'y annuler 40
ans de notre vie mais en même temps j'ai
le sentiment que nous accomplissions une
bonne réaction car le départ des halles
représenter les conséquences économiques
et sociales très importantes
je pense que appelé pas mal d'années
passées ce problème il se confirme que
ce soit sur le plan du quartier que ce
soit avec les habitants du quartier que
ce soit aussi avec un peu comme et
rentre en tout connaissance client il y
avait il y avait vraiment convaincu mais
nous ne savons pas directement ce qui va
se passer voir ici on ne vous a pas
demandé votre avis mais c'est quand on
augmente et je connais la tenue des
comptes vous samedi l'une des très
nombreuses boutiques transformer en
grenier où l'on découvre pêle mêle
chapeau de paille et robes de partie de
campagne une mode du passé pour un
quartier nouveau
on
où sommes-nous ici une boutique ouverte
depuis combien de temps
et puis tout ça parmi les premiers à
s'installer dans cette rue telle idée au
départ devenir installé rue saint-denis
par ascendant des amis locaux
l'intéressé les lotissements les loyers
étaient bon marché à lembach
c'est beau c'est bon aussi mais est ce
que vous avez est ce que vous aviez à
l'époque idée de la clientèle que vous
avez trouvé aujourd'hui tout ce à quoi
vous parlez madame bâ doute est ce que
vous avez envie de dire si on attaquait
dans le quartier est tout seul je
voulais aussi faire pour des fausses
fera quoi alors dit nous racontez nous
un peu ce qui s'est vu le commencement
de des places mondiales tout ça marche a
été un coup dur pour moi pourquoi s'est
traduit par quoi pour vous devez
traduite j'ai perdu à peu près la moitié
de ma clientèle 50 % à 30 % de mon
chiffre d'affaires aussi il faut partir
alors dans des cas pareils aller où
mais un mondial se reconvertir pour quoi
faire
il pas sage est ce que la vie dans le
passage la balle change elle est morte
défini ya trente ans c'était comment
c'était vivons y'a même pas 30 ans il ya
dix ans c'était vivant disney et à tous
les étrangers venaient passer des
soirées tout ça c'est fini
toutes ces petites dames qui étaient là
maintenant on est trois gars ont disparu
tout le monde n'a pas le pessimisme de
monsieur morose
parce que maintenant ça va
un quartier complètement saturé et
il y a ça bouge beaucoup il ya beaucoup
de gens très bien qui habitait au niveau
des bouts de dire qu'il ya des gens en
colère depuis deux mois deux mois et
avec vous dans votre univers où nous
replonger 25 ans en arrière pour quoi
une façon de vie j'appelle ça le stade
achille je crois que c'est une période
où il y avait beaucoup plus de créations
que les bateaux clientèle principalement
étrangère pas du tout les gens du
quartier
quelques quelques personnes du quartier
champ mannequin et le strat
les gens qui vivent aussi comme blanc
dans cette époque
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
découvert passage du cancer monsieur
l'ovi derniers fabricants à paris de
béret basque
depuis le départ des halles c'est
complètement changé il ya des nouvelles
de nouveaux commerces de nouvelles
boutiques avec des beaucoup de jeunes
maintenant qu'ils vendent des articles
tout à fait nouveau j'ai l'impression
que le quartier n'est plus pour vous
n'est plus à vous maintenant c'est la
fin bientôt pour nos autres
la finale
tout est joli si c'est dans les alpes
c'est super
et pensez bien
[Musique]
nous sommes les moins chères 90,6 des
habitants des halles retrouve encore le
pittoresque au marché montorgueil il en
est d'autres expulsés puis relogés qui
ne croient plus en l'avenir
quel effet ça vous a fait devant votre
maison tombée ce soit les mêmes
patineurs parce que ça me fait de la
peine
elle est moralement c'est un chaque
héros lui même de quitter de venir ici
et alors la dernière vous êtes resté
dans une maison était déjà presque morte
une personne qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait
après vous ils ont ils ont commencé
aussi tout était parti par été mises en
lever l'époque les fenêtres ils ont tout
saccagé
vous n'avez pas voulu aller voir au nom
est là le quartier qu'est ce que vous en
pensez qu'ici ça ne change pas beaucoup
mon quartier mais c'est drôlement changé
vous savez qu'il entend bien se débat et
tout ça c'était merveilleux
et là vous vous y retrouvez plus
aujourd'hui où nous on est gardien de
comparable avec lyon 2-2 dans le temps
vous dites que votre oiseau aussi n'at
il n'a pas supporté les ménages mais
eric et le puits qui dessinent chante
plus donc je retiens certain nombre
d'habitants se sont posé le problème de
savoir ce qu'il en serait pour eux
lorsque le marché serait transféré et il
s'est créé une association qui est
devenue l'union des champions cette
association
comment dirais-je a organisé une
première exposition qui a eu pour but de
bloquer l'ensemble de l'aménagement du
quartier en passant si vous voulez d'une
surface de 35 hectares et 20000
habitants expropriés à une surface de 15
hectares et 3000 habitants dans dix ans
comment est ce que vous imaginez la vie
rurale bien dans dix ans je les imagine
fort bien dans toute la mesure où toutes
les classes sociales pourront s'y trouve
est représenté s'il n'y a que des
classes précise
ou des gens très riches ou des gens très
pauvres où règnent des bureaucrates je
crois je dirais presque à la mort de
quartier
[Musique]